on voit le monde comme j'ai un peu peur
de vous je veux c'est un petit technique
pour me déstresser
ça s'appelle le choc moléculaire donc on
secoue un type et je me rend compte
finalement il y aura toujours autant de
monde
alors du coup eh bien je vais vous
proposer quelque chose qui me tient à
coeur c'est à dire d'abord vous dire que
j'ai tout fait pour ne pas venir ici
parce que de la montagne du dimitile on
a l'habitude de voir des touristes et
des marmites d'ailleurs sur le feu de
bois
mais autant de monde dans cette salle
c'est impressionnant on va essayer de
regarder que des gens que je connais
comme ça sera plus facile
alors donc le sujet que j'ai choisi
aujourd'hui c'est l'inattendu un rendez
vous d'exception
alors comme c'est l'inattendu du coup je
suis pas trop qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
vous dire là dessus parce que c'est déjà
rendez vous d'exception de vous
accueillir et d'être avec vous
aujourd'hui je vais quand vous raconter
une anecdote afin d'entrer un peu dans
ce sujet hier ils étaient 16 à 30 et
j'étais en train de dire qu'il fallait
pas que je vienne
j'ai même avertit jennifer et carlo que
comme j'ai du monde ce soir et qu'on va
directement débordé et il était bon que
d'autres personnes plus habilité
farceuse que justement de faire il
savait que carey jennifer montrer tout
de suite
ouais un peu désolé quoi là on va dire
ça comme ça
et du coup je me suis dit bon il faut il
faut faire et juste mais je suis donc à
16h30 en train de me dire une fois des
vêtements parce que je suis en short
habituellement j'ai quand même gardé le
chat pauvres qui me permet d'être venus
de très loin et et puis donc il fallait
aller dans un commerce
mon fils m'appelle et me dit papa vaches
et moutons petit fils j'ai du retard
donc tout ça ça me fait une heure de
plus et puis il est 17h45
grâce à joseph la ville où je suis né et
bien les commerces ferment à 6 heures
donc je descends quand même dans
l'histoire des commerçants à ouvrir et
effectivement il y en a sauf que quand
jacques garreau mon véhicule
ma fille le fait un grand coup en a pas
alors alors donc je discute avec ma
fille et le commerce se faire je me
retrouve donc la veille de mon départ
pour venir vous voir sans vêtements
voilà c'est une situation peut-être pas
inattendu en tout cas n'est pas très
agréable et c'est là ma fille me dit
mais papa si tu veux d'événements vient
chez moi donc mon gendre maintient mardi
alors donc fort de cet équipement
citoyens et citadins je me suis levé ce
matin à 3h50 peut-être l'excitation et
l'inquiétude de faire quelque chose du
bout pour vous fait que je suis arrivé
très tôt ici dans la ville est alors
donc je vais maintenant vous parler de
deux mois parce que c'est ce que je
connais peut-être un peu mieux je
m'appelle valmir turbo c'est pas et
après un autre est connu mais j'étais
rassuré tout de suite passé d'un cinéma
qui m'a dit mais toi tu es un fils
d'esclave
alors parce que le nom sur doigts
étaient des données le show de la
pollution à quelques esclaves dont la
lignée du coup ça m'a rassuré parce que
n'étant pas très black
j'avais du mal auprès des créoles qu'ils
composent la génétique de dire au témoin
les pince oreilles mais voilà aînés
étant plutôt plutôt blanc j'étais tout
de suite adopté d'un familles françaises
en dix ans vous avez un accent monsieur
donc en conséquence black and white
voilà ce que je suis avec donc une
richesse puisque du coup mes amis sont
allés chercher jusqu'au source de ma
généalogie et ils ont découvert que le
frasil qui entre autres veut dire bonne
parole phrase ya sept hameaux grecque et
menthe en 1789 elle a fait la lignée de
mon père jusqu'à mon grand père tout le
monde était black
qu'est ce que mon grand père a fait et
s'est marié à une blanche du coup ça
éclaircit mon père qui n'a jamais pu
voir qu'il était vraiment black et maman
avec son sang breton puisque 15 breton
fait sa ligne et un moment et deux de
l'isère ça donnait donc une grosse
perturbation génétique vraisemblement un
cyclone et et le cyclone est devant vous
valmir black and white
alors on a commencé à faire un voyage à
travers le d'inattendu je n'ai presque
normalement mais avec une gastro
entérite
donc mes jours sont un peu en danger et
je n'ai surtout dans une terre brûlée
le thème de qui va supporter mon
intervention
ce sera la terre brûlée parce que il ya
aujourd'hui une répercussion au niveau
des sociétés ou de niveau des événements
que nous connaissons
alors la nièvre oublie c'est que
justement maman à cet enfant est un
enfant meurt brûlé vif donc du coup ma
marais eu un réflexe avait fait de
protéger tous les enfants de surprotéger
les premiers sont allés en france dont
pendant 40 ans je n'ai pratiquement pas
vu mais donc défaire mes frères et
soeurs et nous étions des deux des amies
les mamans se poser la question qu'est
ce qu'on allait faire que ces deux
derniers elle a trouvé cette charmante
et des communautés
elle travaille à l'église catholique le
curé un jour nous présente un évêque
monseigneur langavant alors cette
présentation est en fait elle me dit
comment tu le trouves à l'âge de 11 ans
je vais trouver gentil koala et du coup
je me suis retrouvé au séminaire de
cilaos dans une voie toute tracée ce
qu'on appelle la tendu et donc
normalement c'est diack vécurent et je
ne sais pas si c'est une vraie justice
pour vous d'apprendre que j'ai hate you
ont pu le l'attendu et donc je ne suis
pas que est désolé pour ceux qui pensent
que c'est bon et donc il y avait des
filles qui sont passés par là j'ai
remarqué que la femme finalement était
un centre d'intérêt majeur pour la
plupart des hommes et donc j'ai vu qu'au
fond de moi il y avait une attente que
je n'ai su explorer voilà alors mais
maman n'a pas n'a pas dit son dernier
mot
parce que sont-ils du séminaire que j'ai
dû donc trouver une excuse auprès de
monseigneur l'évêque de l'île de la
réunion
dès que je suis arrivé avec le bac
maman a tout de suite vu dans le journal
recherche bacheliers pour devenir
enseignant et elle voulait à tout prix
me garantir c'était un réflexe et une ma
sécurité était de trouver un enseignant
ça finit tu m'as n'est attendue
retraités et à l'époque c'était un homme
riche à l'enseignant aujourd'hui paraît
que c'est pas tout à fait ça et donc du
coup me voilà embarquée dans
l'enseignement
gd le troisième voie voulu sortir de
cette affaire-là
ça a été un peu plus long et et a lobé
mon père est bien mon père je l' ai
toujours aimé je les ai d aller dans les
gens étaient agriculteurs spécialisés en
fruits et légumes
et puis de la distillerie de géranium et
du vétiver mais il ne disait pas trop
grand choix dans ma vie un fort
caractère et du cou et du coup même si
le désir est au fond de lui et j'ai
compris plus tard que je devienne
agriculteurs et l'avait vu que sa
constance n'est pas bonne pour
s'exprimer et
c'est là que avec au fil du temps j'ai
développé trois ou quatre métiers
simultanées ainsi pour juste le plaisir
j'étais le premier exportateur de fruits
et légumes à l'âge de 18 ans vers
l'alsace
à cette époque là les avions n'étaient
que les avions passagers dont c'était le
commandant de bord qui prenaient une
facture pour cette expédition
et puis j'ai fait à bordeaux l'un vers
ce jeu j'ai créé un peu plus tard une
boutique exotiques exactement à la teste
de buch
ce bassin d'arcachon et pendant 5 ans je
vendais des samoussas et des pompes
alors j'étais en train de me fourvoyer
dans les tas de trucs que je considérais
comme inutile parce que j'ai eu aussi
des sociétés qui ont coulé avant même
qu'elle se lève et et du coup je me suis
dit ça va ça va pas et la peur peut il
ya comme quelque chose de l'intérieur
l'esn attendu est toujours là à tout
seconde à tout moment pour s'échapper de
nous comme un parfum le parfum de notre
essentiel et il est arrivé j'avais 49
ans à 49 ans je décide de devenir un cas
aviculteurs je vais donc à l'école parce
qu'il faut aller à l'école maintenant de
l'agriculture enfin il ya le lycée est
donc lâchage obtient un brevet
professionnel agricole est muni de ce
brevet dont je suis encore fier et
puisque je suis toujours un véhicule tôt
en titre et et bien je j'ai entrepris de
faire des pépinières des fleurs et le
hasard des choses m'ont amené vers la
plante aromatique et la plante
médicinale qui représente l'essentiel de
mon activité agricole et là j'ai
retrouvé une paix intérieure
j'ai retrouvé ce que je souhaite à tout
le monde d'ailleurs c'est de vous
rapprocher le plus de la nature parce
que la nature témoigne de notes nature
nous sommes fait des mêmes éléments qui
sont autour de nous et nous sommes ces
éléments là nous penser nos émotions
comme unique il y en a même qui donne
des musiques automates vous voyez
donc il ya une grande richesse à vivre
dans la nature
si bien que naturellement j'ai été
propulsé vers ledit métier-là 1812 m où
cette fois ci j'étais au coeur de la
nature
ce que je n'ai pas qui a été donc mon
inattendu là où elle a dit mme utile
c'est que j'étais en train de faire de
l'agriculture biologique justement des
expériences sur les tomates et que
finalement tout les toutes les deux ou
trois heures quelqu'un passé vous avez
de l'eau s'il vous plaît qu'est ce que
vous faites là
bon ben voilà et maintenant que ben ça
fait neuf ans que je suis à dimitile etc
c'est des jeunes de 25 35 qui viennent
là aux communes un lieu de ressourcement
de recherche de soi peut-être à transit
pour aller rillieux donc l'inattendue
est un peu ça c'est à dire que c'est
quelque chose qu'on a en nous peut-être
avant de venir sur la terre peut-être
que nous choisissons nos parents et par
la baisse
et peut-être que nous ne mourront jamais
dans l'inattendu ya le même joueur peut
jouer plusieurs fois et du coup cette
démarche intérieure m'amener à fait des
rencontres exceptionnelles
tout d'abord avec des ouvrages et là ça
revient monty pas ce curé un copain de
mon lycée agricole m'offrait un livre le
titre maïs riz conversation avec dieu
alors je me suis dit non c'est pas
possible maintenant plus parler à dieu
alors donc j'ai laissé au moins une
semaine le bouquin de côté je me dis non
non fait bronzer et donnait six ans dans
le milieu c'est bon et finalement le cas
il me rappelle et me dit mais alors
comment tu trouves le bouquin je dis
c'est pas mal bon j'ai un peu menti j'ai
dit c'est pas mal mais je vais le garder
encore un peu et finalement je commence
à lla l'arrière je lis en croisé et puis
je tombe sur d'autres plutôt bizarre
jeudi il ya un génie quelques pins et je
croyais que c'était l'auteur du bouquin
qu'il devait l'être aussi jours et après
l'avoir lu j'ai pas trop compris grand
chose mais ce que j'ai surtout compris
ceux qui fabriquent je lui rende le
bouquin et c'est là qu'ils me temps le
deuxième c'est comme speed aspect 2 et 3
il y avait trois ouvrages il attendait
déjà à l'ordre
j'ai pu résister au premier bouquin je
n'ai pas su résister au droit mais ça a
été une première école magnifique une
école vers quelque chose d'insaisissable
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui nous sommes
conscients
je suis sur chacun d'entre vous que nous
sommes en train de déshumaniser la
planète terre et 7 de cette chose-là et
et ça nous rend perplexe en fait parce
que si vous êtes l'un tous c'est que
nous partageons tous cette richesse de
l'humain c'est votre quête je le sens je
sens que vous vous avez une énergie
extraordinaire et je remercie au passage
d'eads x à cette belle initiative parce
que nous sommes vraiment dans un moment
que j'ai appelé tout à l'heure la terre
brûlée c'est à dire qu'il faut que de
nouvelles graines sort de cette terre et
les incendies ou les tragédies sont
souvent une école du renouveau et
l'école qui donne de la cohésion de
l'unité notre société nos sociétés ont
besoin d'unité
et surtout lorsque nous tremblons dans
nos individualités
nous avons besoin de nous retrouver
comme aujourd'hui
et puis d'aller plus loin à l'intérieur
de nous car entre chiens entre chacun
d'entre nous élire à cette richesse de
l'essentiel est notre essentiel se
partagent ce partage facilité étonnante
alors donc j'étais en train de voyager
dans ma vie et puis donc vous avez
découvert que finalement le black and
white que je suis a été une école de
tolérance et d'ouverture
ce qui fait que j'ai appris à découvrir
justement que aucun être ce septet ne
soit pas le ferez à la nôtre est ne
serait-ce d'un point de vue biologique
il semblerait qu'il aurait que deux pour
cent d'une race venus d'ailleurs
peut-être des intérêts ce niveau sinon
les terian sont à 98% du même jeune
homme et ça c'est bon à savoir
alors donc après avoir fait tous ce
voyage autour de mon être et plus
exactement à l'intérieur je me suis
rendu compte que les inattendus
eh bien allez devenir riche et ferris
ans j'avais mis mes pieds dans une
fourmilière d'inattendu alors on va
donner quelques petites choses pour moi
le plus grand inattendu c'est que c'est
la fin de set
cette intervention est
je terminerai avec justement la phrase
de la faim qui arrive un quart d'heure
peut-être non c'est ça fait du mahatma
gandhi la patience infinie donne des
résultats immédiats